Holloway
[Applause]
Miriam
there's well we go into the donkey
and we can debate here
[Applause]
and finally we've got this going
[Applause]
I like it a lot
[Applause]
welcome everybody
we're so fed a deer talk a little bit
about last season and obviously getting
the new season as well I don't want to
jump into the beginning and talk about
last season feeling very different than
the other confusing so exotic
absolutely starter for all you guys on
the mountain is jumpin how much fun was
that for you or what did you love about
kind of going a little bit darker
getting a little more emotional is so
much more fun to be bad take it you know
a little bit start Earl of an edge here
that was great
go ahead jumping off of it and joking
about some the stuff that we saw
we've seen ego hole killer frost we've
seen full Caitlin snow and I kind of
come out on top of immunity that this
news is just going to be like blaze
flurries or something like same
no matter where is she going to be in
the next season kind of I mean they're
like Caitlin snow let's kill her frog
yeah good news no one's going to be
disappointed that was a good answer very
politically correct she didn't give too
much away perfect the practicing all day
I love it so we obviously got full dark
from Caitlin snow cleared from class
season also stabbed her obviously being
the big fat of the season for all of you
guys when did you know that it was
actually going to be a different version
of Barry and having that kind of impact
you're acting on the show I knew pretty
early on it didn't obviously effect too
much for me to Barry didn't know but
yeah I knew pretty early on
does everybody know pretty early on yeah
you caught me looking up really fast
oh that's how that stuff supposedly
basically sounds like and that's why we
don't fall in love with one of my
favorite teams on this season as well
was obviously when Grant you were acting
against yourself can you talk a little
bit about doing that same did you have
another actor in there what was that
like for you playing both sides yeah we
had this guy Andrew Dunbar that was
awesome it was really fun
Tom Cavanagh and right here this guy yep
he directs
that means a lot because we obviously
have a very strong working relationship
and we are strong relationship all just
get along general it wasn't necessarily
easy material and having a scene with
yourself that's emotionally charged now
I can speak tonight expect a little bit
because you won't complement himself but
you know he he is granted as a
phenomenal actor and then when you see
him at the nuances and let me just fit
okay all right you know and they're just
a little the smaller layers between the
two and then bring it both of them play
the scene that he had to do when he was
playing against himself with very strong
and emotional powerful scenes and to
watch an hour after hour bring the 600 G
for one character and then match it with
his different energy but equally
powerful energy was it was an acting
clinic it was great to watch but also
very handsome thank you thank you well
speaking of playing different versions
of yourself Tom we got to see so many
the reversion of Harrison from all
different texts I don't know which one
is my favorite but what was that like
for you kind of jumping in between all
those different versions well it turns
out WB ran the numbers and the numbers
there 33 times over in the numbers and
they found that the show's success runs
inversely to how many wells as I play
really
and basically they also took from that
to the screen time alone if I'm on show
dips so it doesn't really matter what I
think it seems like right now we're
going to concentrate on different things
right got it again for the good show
good I love it well there's a thousand
different Wells and we'll we'll we'll
introduce some more I'm sure as the
season progresses you and I only can
imagine you practicing and figuring out
what those other verses are just becomes
are you talking it's just like how about
this poor dog poor dog he does he
actually sent me a video on time of like
four or five different wells that was Oh
awesome is video awesome is one word for
the video message is that it's at GNN
I like cowboy well got worried about
yeah you need to make a comeback oh my
gosh I don't offend over these nobody is
calling for the buyer
nobody warns about and the ones out
there can't process can you
all of those versions need to be on the
extras I'm just saying that right now so
fingers crossed from hi
oh let's stop talking about obviously
they said that there's not too many
secrets between you guys but when did
you know that your character was
actually going to serve on Isaac again
very early on because of Grant Gustin
literally no producer has ever told me
that I wasn't going to die thanks I
remember telling all that you should
tell Candace because she's going to read
that script yeah no one told me so
thanks for grant you can you answer you
earlier I did eventually told you I just
thought there was like stories coming up
you're going to die you're not really
going to die so don't worry you've got a
job okay cool cool I love that pretty
early on I knew I was safe looking out
yeah yeah oh my god my sweet seriously
not tell you one thing I lose the love
between you guys is really a life and
imma show grid like some his favor and
research you I love it I love hearing
about the villains that you guys are
gonna bring it obviously it changes the
dynamic of what team flash has to do
what is it this season that you guys are
really trying to go for in that way last
year obviously was avatar and it was
very nice very it really good trying to
save iris
yeah well I mean you know this year it's
with three speedsters in a row that we
did you want to change it up so the
thinker the way that we're sort of
explained is is the fastest man alive
versus the fastest mind alive oh that
wasn't going to be like mm-hmm
we're also I mean a big thing this year
is we're really trying to lighten the
tone a little bit last year we got first
car and we want to get back
[Music]
the tone of a bit for Linux cubed grande
where you just like yeah next season I'm
in the speedforce peace out guys yeah I
thought I was going to show up anyway
the season yeah but not on the show as
if we can get into it a little more -
where are we going to pick up because
obviously in the season ended with you
kind of taking over the mantle of the
flash in Central City where yeah I mean
it's sort of how I view it is like well
you had to step up not necessarily step
board I think the whole team has to come
together and be like how do we make this
machine work without the guy that was
that our leaves you know and so
everyone's sort of just having to band
together and do what we can with this
sort of like sad situation and find the
love and find the life wherever it is
possible so I think while in sort of
growing up you're finding a sense of
freedom and self-confidence with them
stuff that isn't as cocky as it was less
but yeah I think they're really just
trying to be there for each other to do
it this navigate this whole situation
[Applause]
and refit events with different
characters about if you're going to have
to go into the season and we saw some of
it in that little teaser trailer
everyone's dealing with the fact that
ferry is gone how does that affect each
of your characters moving forward if you
can share any event make-ahead school
yeah well okay for me iris I mean she's
devastated
[Applause]
she's devastated that she's gone into
the three boards and that they didn't
really have a discussion about it he
just took off and left so we pick up
season four iris is kind of focused or
energy on being the leaders of some kind
of steps up and leaves that leave the
team which is really really cool yeah I
think it's a cool kind of transition
from last season words like not that you
couldn't save yourself you were working
to but the whole team was working
together to save you and now you get to
be the one who's like let's all do this
together yeah yeah I've heard about this
oh my girl I love it I love it girl good
girl for killer frost at this point can
you talk at all about where she's gone
where she's been who's obviously she
says she's leaving but we saw her in
that footage but who did you see correct
so good I'm really excited in this how
proud of you are amazing
she's not going to work I'm against it
Daniel knows all the secrets on the show
he's the one who keeps her lips really
true like I said you know obviously have
a huge fan of the show for you guys
being on it I know that you have moments
that really stand out for you is there a
scene in particular an episode for each
of you guys that really sticks out from
last season I really like getting to do
the episode of town directed you know
where we got to go eight years in the
future and playing versions of our
character is
you know in a what-if situation yeah
they've had a lot of fun to play and I
revisit those sets you know in this
weird way were their own destroyed and
leaves everywhere and it's really cool
and that was fun for me first thing for
the favorite moments just watching you
know this cast do they don't know when
you're in a scene you're involved -
you're playing your character you're
nothing you're that's my dad come on
we're lunch what it's not time yet she
says get legal that go ahead and guess
so anyway but watch them to watch them
while you're at the monitor you're not
embassy just watch them act and perform
it's this stunning amount of talent to
be able to witness to be part of it on a
daily basis I just felt like a real
privilege
yeah the Christmas scene from me and
that episode really fun oh you're
amazing
ha it was only one moment there's one
more way to the team flash thing or
grande myself cheers tom felton that's
what I was about today so there's no way
a lot of times we colloquially refer to
ourselves as team flash this is team
flash there's a moment where all yes
Maxine we're y'all like we'd fashion
this moment where we all kind of put our
hands in and we say team flash and
grants besides and we hadn't rehearse it
not as the guys I want to try to thank
for all the girly your hand good a baby
with her hands and resent team flash and
I started from
and he mocks me said I made it even
better anyway you were mostly crying
because of the real-life situation of
what we don't did that it got me a G
black Jessie flash looks we got that
because I think that means for me for
sure it comes across so much on the show
that you guys really do have a huge love
for each other and a huge support and as
you guys have said so much of an
exacting that you guys keep pushing each
other further and further and I think
the emotions that we saw last season it
stood out so much for each and every one
of you guys on the panel out here and
for all the guests starting co-stars as
well
what were the moments where they're
asking you guys they really stood out
from us even so many I mean for me the
scene you brought up was what it was
most challenging scene I did last year
which comes episode just because I was
my own scene partner and there was a
crazy wig it was product both guys had a
lot to say I mean it was challenging
when I was leaving one guy was broken
when do ya giving up it was it was
phenomenal yeah so yeah I think for me
flashpoint
the first episode of again there is
something kind of light and fun about it
I always enjoyed those moments on the
show it was also really cool to have
that brother-sister crime-fighting me I
[Applause]
have to say the last episode of the
season because it was so damn emotional
yeah and I didn't know what to think
about that like where would we go from
there like if he literally walks away
from all of us including his fiancee
into a place where he may never ever
return where do we go from there
I mean we're finding out now but you
know well not everything we're finding
out little pieces find out more oh my
god we found out various doesn't know
anything like it
that's true yeah for me yeah me with
bunch point because the first time I
suited up it's good flash no it's very
so very full of lots of emotions I'm
very afraid
I'm very nervous and I'm also so excited
because it's like obviously that was a
very cool dream of mine as a kid so it's
still obviously go like kids so it feels
very fitting yeah great did you give
them any advice for the first time that
is putting on the face like stupid like
practical advice like about your neck
and stuff and like because in my blood
you help me do the slide and that's
right we worked on the slide oh yeah
I'll try again the thing but I remember
the car one of your first shots was like
laying in the dumpster and I was like
okay look this is what you can do to
like work the next because the suits are
kind of you know kind of the but well I
mean you need somebody to tell you that
because like when you're taking an
Instagram photo and really I make sure I
look really good here like that up one
thing yes yes good photo for your first
second this to doesn't look as good as
it possibly can so good advice great
yeah well did you as a remote in London
I think for me maybe it was the musical
set episode because for me when Greg and
Andrew like yeah you and your brother
going to write this one we're like wait
what like we don't know anything about
musicals so it was it was it was a
challenge but it was a lot of fun I need
to you know watch dailies and see these
guys it was it was pretty amazing
experience
well I know that everybody out here has
some awesome favorite moment from last
week's season as well so right now we're
going to do is take some questions from
you guys for our panel up here until
something where you guys going to be Oh
Kleber well I mean
you need to give them some advice on
that sir what's your name from what
requested class my name is Alec Kudo I'm
actually from Mexico word bag I actually
made you guys last year this is my
second year in the in comic-con so
excited welcome back guys good job
okay the question is are there going to
be any more crossovers yes efsun
analyzed and we're being rocking
everywhere I love it
thank you my question was inspires kind
of payroll and getting very I needed
speed for great question great question
um yeah degree yeah I think though yeah
of course yeah sure okay I see I can't
remember that's why I'm taking so long
Wow but yes she does she like I said
she's kind of boss lady a team flash now
so she's an active four six been to get
in there man out of it before
[Music]
all right let's do name them what's your
question I'm lazy I kind of a question
that the musical episode
I don't know whoever last year the panel
someone shouted flash musical yep that
was me
[Applause]
perfect hi would you say what is the
musical talent behind everyone's
exposition or say I'm share with music
balance with Graham being ugly is that
right you're ugly
alright breviary right Lindsey shut up
something else and we'll do that - she
was in China where's the inspiration
from where the inspiration come from for
the musical of food you know it's just
when you have a cast like this I can do
anything
you know and it's also great for
Lansing's a huge lover of musicals and
so it's really his brainchild behind it
so yeah you know you don't you guys
thank Rick all right who is our next
question of your what's your name hide
in with the questions we just mentioned
indicated nice eyes nice shirt yeah -
again what is gonna be romantic and
beautiful I you know I gotta right now
we don't know when it's going to be
whenever Lindsay shouts it out and then
we're going to do that next you know
thank you
hi let me answer season fun hiya what's
your name what's your question three
angel in the house here hi guys you guys
are awesome what's up
I want to take this opportunity to thank
all of you but Tom's way that you have
differentiated all the different Wells
has been some of the greatest acting
that I've ever witnessed
and I want to know as an actor what do
you do to prepare for those type of
differentiation
well first off thank you a lot of times
I get a little more credit than I
deserve you have to remember that
there's a team of people writing you
know there's a team of people trying to
forge what the storylines are not just
for me but for you know everybody here
and they spent a lot of time in the
writers room coming up with those kind
of things and then they write the words
and then I hit a mark and say those
words and people think that maybe I
created those words but I didn't
necessarily you know and so for me when
when coming up with it different well
the one thing I've tried to do because
everybody on the stage is so winning
when when coming up with Terry I thought
well maybe if there was a guy who's a
bit of a jackass you know is that what
helped because we need a little bit of
antagonism a daily antagonist to them on
season three we were a little darker I
thought maybe if we had a little bit
more humor that might be a place for
that and then season four I'm just going
to sing the whole time
thank you Oh God
I'm not now that is a little preview of
what dear David was requested hi my name
is Jennifer miracle Netflix I recently
caught up as we found out exam and I
thank you very much
yes thank you I look confused and I was
talking to him he might be able to
explain how Savitz are existed in the
first place it all had to kill virus to
exist when exactly did I respond
you are dr. Q who
humans don't understand yoohoo there's a
reason why we're not doing time travel
anymore season four right we'll have a
sidebar it's a long long explanation I'm
like Meza need to save time travel I've
tried to Connie one I've moved on okay
what's your name and is our last
question I was getting like a question
my name is Evelyn and I just wanted to
say grant you're my hero okay thank you
for being alive my question odd and mom
if we not see so many birds so many
birds is American well and that Harry is
Jesse quick fathers was wearing maybe on
another earth we'll see
Johnny quick come on Hannah painter it's
just from first off I love it you
complimented grant and got mad got a
question I like that yeah I feel like
one of the things we've done is your
organic degree and like you said all
these different multi resulting
different options every earth is an
option and so yet Johnny quick is an
option for Todd yeah I mean we like to
pull from all the characters from the
comic book so I mean there's a whole
list of people that we want to do in the
future whether that happens sooner than
later yet to be determined but yeah then
the whole list of potential people that
Tom could play
you